(triumphant music)
- You have some ideas in
your head about what it means
to be a father; but now that
I'm going to be a father,
there's a lot of fear, honestly.
(multiple babies crying)
- [Instructor] All right, rookie dads--
- [David] When you walk
into the classroom--
- [Instructor] Rookie dads,
now go ahead and have a seat.
- It's intense.
There's a lot of diapers,
crying, and we're all nervous.
We don't know what to expect.
- Take a good look at Nick, here.
This is your Ghost of
Christmas Future, OK?
(laughing)
These guys, last six months,
is what your next six
months looks like, OK?
Helping these guys prepare
for their future as dads
is basically about providing them
with some really simple insights.
Moms like facing the babies.
Dads tend to turn the babies around,
face the babies out into the world.
We talk about how dad
is instinctively wired
to be a protector.
And a simple preparation
now can dramatically change
how things happen in the future.
You are going into a nesting phase, too.
You are actually gonna go through
about a 33 percent drop in testosterone.
It'll come back.
(laughing)
- There are so many things that concern me
about becoming a parent.
Even things like how to
hold your baby properly,
and just keeping the house up around us
and the ground underneath us.
- It's hard to overstate how
pivotal the preparation is
that we have these guys do.
And set her right there.
Before he lets her go, I'm gonna
wrap her up like this, OK?
Quite a significant percentage
of the guys who come
to this class have never
held a baby before.
- I wasn't expecting to actually
hold someone else's child.
It's an immediate reality check.
(baby crying)
- Hand on that shoulder.
And then you pat him about that hard,
and see if anything comes out.
- OK.
- It's a watershed moment.
This guy who's never
held a baby before says,
"Wait a second, I'm doing this."
- You look natural.
(baby squeals)
Before I walked into
the class as a rookie,
I probably would have
said that I was prepared.
It was only after I took
the class that I came out
realizing, wow, I don't know anything.
(laughs)
- The veteran dads really were very open
about their experiences, and passed around
their children to complete strangers.
Very brave.
- The best way to prepare
for your kid's future,
financially or emotionally or spiritually,
is to take the time to
get your stuff together.
- The buck stops with you, right?
That's the role that you're
stepping into as a parent.
- [Instructor] We've got this
square dance going on here;
this is kind of fun.
(laughing)
The last thing I do at
Boot Camp for New Dads,
is I ask a really simple question:
"What are two words you want
your child to say about you
"when they have a chance?"
- I hope that they would
answer that I was loving
and that I was patient.
- Yeah, that's a good question.
I know that it's an
opportunity to grow and be sure
that you're in a position to lead someone
to a future you feel they deserve.
- [Voiceover] Whether you're
a rookie parent or a veteran,
New York Life has you covered.
Start a plan that flexes with yours.